[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction sur tv fil 78 voici les titres
en images de ce mardi 28 mars 2017
l'institut de transition énergétique vd
comme fête ses trois ans de nombreuses
innovations dévoilées aujourd'hui depuis
satory et qu'il devrait rendre l'avenir
de l'automobile encore plus écologique
environnement et la technique du zéro
phyto qui tend à se généraliser
plusieurs communes font le choix de
supprimer voire de réduire quelquefois
les pesticides pour des démarches plus
naturel pour entretenir les espaces
verts c'est le cas de la commune de
montigny le bretonneux et puis à damien
béal est à la fois maroquinier est
ébéniste il façonne des pièces uniques
dans son atelier de versailles est c'est
ça que se transforme en objets de
décoration c'est notre portrait du mardi
dans le cadre des journées européennes
des métiers d'art et des perturbations
aujourd'hui sur le réseau et ski bus les
conducteurs de moby site est l'un des
quatre transporteurs de l'entreprise
sont entrés en grève illimitée 14
salariés et qui réclame à la direction
une augmentation des salaires la ligne
et 466 et qui passe notamment par le
technocentre renault la ligne 414 entre
à montigny le bretonneux et rap ont été
fortement impactés on écoute les
revendications des grévistes
au micro de michael et demi d'euros
aujourd'hui on a touché un salaire de
1300 à 1400 à 1400 euros
les minimums et 2300 le maximum est de
1400 euros
depuis hier soir nous sommes ici nous
sommes tous fatigués on n'a pas mangé
on n'a pas dormi et on ne sait pas
comment je n'a pas vu nono nos femmes
nos enfants on n'a vu personne une
famille on n'a vu personne donc à ce
moment là nous sommes tous révoltés et
on veut que ces gens du soutien cela ne
se reproduise plus est ce pour ça qu'on
se mobilise pour que cette chose là ne
se reproduise plus il faut qu'on soit
respectée et dans la tente de
discussions avec la direction attention
dans les prochains jours si vous devez
utiliser ces lignes renseignements
pratiques sur le site de la société sqy
bus transporte toujours mais innovations
cette fois ci avec l institut français
de recherche et de formation dédié à la
lité individuel décarbonés et durable
qui fête ses trois ans 3 ans et
d'innovation à l'honneur aujourd'hui sur
le site de satory près de versailles
comme a pu le constater nicolas quirion
la voiture que nous conduiront demain et
probablement en phase d'élaboration ici
à satory l'un des sites où est basé vd
comme l'institut pour la transition
énergétique et créer en 2014 travaille
actuellement sur près d'une vingtaine de
projets et profite de son troisième
anniversaire pour les faire découvrir à
ses partenaires nous disons que nous
voulons être l'écosystème qui génèrent
ces nouvelles mobilités l'écosystème de
référence et nous voulons être le
pionnier de ces nouvelles mobilités
élevé des com compte désormais 150
collaborateurs pour développer ces
différents axes de recherche comme
l'électrification des véhicules
objectifs permettent de réduire la
consommation d'énergie et les émissions
de polluants principe à l'inauguration
cette année la piste qui recharge
directement la batteries des voitures
électriques
on peut l'imaginer au travers de la
charge en roulant qu'elle soit continu
comme on le fait sur la piste fabrique
coupe ce soit en biberonnage c'est à
dire avoir des spots où on charge quand
on s'arrête on peut effectivement
imaginer se déplacer sans consommer
d'énergie sur la batterie doté d'un
budget de 25 millions d'euros annuels bd
comme poursuit son développement l'an
prochain l'ensemble de ces activités
seront rassemblés à satory dans des
nouveaux locaux de la voiture au vélo
nous en parlons à présent de l'opération
cyclo-défi redonner confiance aux jeunes
des quartiers populaires à travers le
sport c'est l'objectif de cette course
vtt à travers tout le département des
yvelines elle va démarrer à ce dimanche
depuis le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mais avant de s'élancer il faudra se
préparer à leur langue
faty vie à mantes la jolie elle sera
dimanche au départ du cyclo-défi
qu'organise l'association solidarité
handicap france cameroun avant d'avaler
des kilomètres de routes
il lui faut d'abord apprendre à réparer
engrais tt bonjour voici comment tu vas
c'est va bien on va t'expliquer un petit
peu comment est ce que tu peux faire
pour entretenir mon ton vélo avant de
partir en randonnée comme tu prépares le
le tour des yvelines avec tous tes
petits copains la semaine prochaine à
travers le vélo
association veut permettre aux jeunes
yvelinois de quartiers prioritaires
situés notamment à elancourt et
guyancourt de prendre en main un projet
d'être responsables de leur destin
alors aujourd'hui on a appris quelques
règles de sécurité à faty un déjà de
vérifier de savoir enlever sa enlever sa
roue et la remettre de bien vérifier
qu'elles soient bien serré à réparer une
chambre r c'est ce qui arrive le prive
plus fréquemment c2c de crever une
formule que sidonie et bonga
coordinatrice de l'événement a importé
du canada s'émanciper grâce au sport le
concept là tout de suite séduit il
permet aux participants de sortir de
leur environnement quotidien et d'aller
découvrir le département en profondeur
culturellement économiquement
géographiquement l'enjeu n'est pas
seulement d'apporter du bien-être aux
jeunes mais aussi de changer les
représentations vis-à-vis des banlieues
l'ambition de donner une image aussi des
jeunes du quartier priorités qui soit
non seulement celle des casseurs des
pires doudène l'époque mais celle aussi
des jeunes qui veulent s'intégrer à ce
jour la course compte une trentaine de
participants et il est toujours possible
de s'inscrire
si le succès est au rendez vous
l'événement sera reconduit l'an prochain
la france troisième utilisateurs au
monde de pesticides pour réduire cette
consommation les initiatives existent
c'est le cas du zéro phyto comment
entretenir les espaces verts sans
produits chimiques
la ville de montigny le bretonneux a
fait ce choix est fait aujourd'hui
figure de très bon élève dans le
département haussmann vendeurs d patrick
jacques de dixmude
voilà cinq ans que montigny le
bretonneux a décidé de prendre la route
du zéro phyto ce pesticide est un vrai
problème sanitaire selon une étude du
ministère de la santé
il est à l'origine de cancers de
troubles de la reproduction ou encore la
maladie de parkinson
il a fallu revoir effectivement toutes
les pratiques parce que traiter c'est
facile en quelques heures on est capable
de traiter des plusieurs centaines de
mètres de trottoirs ou des espaces verts
aujourd'hui le travail est peut-être
plus fastidieux aussi mais les
jardiniers ont sans former régulièrement
la ville souhaite aussi sensibiliser le
public selon une étude du ministère de
la santé 30 % de la pollution des eaux
pourrait être causée par les usages non
agricoles
à partir du 1er janvier 2019 les
particuliers ne pourront plus utiliser
de produits phytosanitaires
enfin particuliers et non non
professionnel de façon plus générale
ils ont des impacts à la fois sur la
santé humaine sur l'environnement
et nous dans notre démarche plus
particulièrement au niveau de la
protection de la ressource
car on retrouve ses produits dans
l'ensemble du cycle de l'eau depuis le
1er janvier 2017 les communes sont
soumises à la loi la baie elle interdit
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires sur les espaces publics
[Musique]
chaque semaine nous allons à la
rencontre d'un yvelinois d'une
yvelinoise dans ce journal aujourd'hui
direction versailles au travail
l'artisan damien béal est à la fois
maroquinier est ébéniste il fait partie
de ces artisans qui exposeront leur
savoir faire lors des journées
européennes des métiers d'art fin mars
dans quelques jours son portrait est
signée camille lambert un sac le
compagnon d'une vie dans son atelier
damien b elle donne naissance à ses
partenaires du quotidien il crée une
alliance de deux matériaux aussi noble
que naturel le bois et le cuir les deux
matières sont proches le fait de
travailler récurer paix sert un joie
quand on travaille par exemple un
plaquage pour des bois donc un bois
plutôt fin mais ça se rejoint dans ce
sens et un rapport pour la découpe du
cuir ça se coupe avec une lame de cutter
ce qui peut être la même chose pour
couper de voir ces du perçage c'est de
la géométrie c'est de la découpe
c'est assez naturel dans le temps vous
êtes bien des mâles en bois et en cuir
qui étaient cloués c'est une autre façon
de marier ces deux matières quand on les
touche oui à une c'est un rapport à la
sensation à l'odorat à la face à ce lien
là et du coup c'est à sa part est en
fait assez évident après un ca paix
menuiserie damien devient ébéniste chez
les compagnons du devoir puis monte son
entreprise
quinze ans plus tard c'est grâce à une
amie qu'il débute dans la création avec
un premier sac en 2014 une amie qui est
mosaïste qui me demande de lui fabriquer
pour une exposition un sac tout en bois
et donc je fais ce sac l incruste de la
mosaïque pour décorer donc c'est une
pièce conférence en collaboration et du
tout la démarche créative autour de cet
objet malien ne m'a amené à réfléchir un
objet sac et du coup j'ai c'est là que
l'idée est venue de garder une partie du
bois de le remplacer par un autre
matière pour en l'objet
facile à utiliser au quotidien octobre
2014 l'artisan lance sa collection
quotidien pour ce week end minimum des
noms attribués selon la taille de chaque
objet de la coupe et la couture tous
sont créés à la main un savoir faire qui
passe aussi par le choix des pièces
c'est un tannage sans chrome donc le sac
yves à spa thinel en fait les couleurs
peuvent bouger un peu dans le temps est
toujours en fait j'aime bien l'idée
qu'un objet que vous que le fait de
vieillir soit aux racines
d'embellissement que l'averse et pour se
démarquer il possède sa propre signature
donc chaque sac a donc une couture bleu
blanc rouge d'une surpiqûre il a une
date de naissance du jour où il est
terminé
officier il a été fait le 3 février 2010
est une confection qui a un coût de 100
à 800 euros le sac
cela fait un an que damien des halles
est installé rue royale à versailles un
atelier boutique où sont accueillis
clients et curieux
on n'est pas forcément dans l'attende
action on travaille toute la journée en
fabriquant on nous voit en vitrine il se
trouve que l'espace permet d'exposer des
sacs
donc les gens peuvent venir avec plaisir
mais c'est un lieu où il n'y a pas
d'horaire on n'est pas commerçant mais
on est artisan vraiment lieu les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir des
créations uniques comme ce modèle
réalisé en partenariat avec un tatoueur
pour les journées européennes des
métiers d'art damien fera des
démonstrations au public
rendez vous donc ce week-end du côté de
versailles et pour refermer ce journal
les images de l'unique projection en
salle du documentaire toi même tu filmes
initiée par la plateforme internet de
partage vidéo youtube c'était attrape au
grenier à sel à 40 minutes pour
découvrir comment des jeunes de 50
communes ont réfléchi à des courts
métrages de 90 secondes autour d'un même
thème la fraternité et le choix de
trapèze n'est pas anodin à écouter on
est ravi de pouvoir annoncer et dévoilé
pour la première fois le
documentaire qui raconte la tournée toi
même tu film est donc passé par 50
villes et qui l'a aujourd'hui va
s'arrêter sur huit dates particulières
il entra pour avoir énormément de
l'extrait qui sont passés à la trappe à
l'espace jeunes de trappes et donc tout
l'idée c'est de voir un peu les
coulisses de la tournée nous les jeunes
on a envie de s p mais mon corps n'est
pas la meilleure façon de faire et ils
nous ont donné la une d une des
meilleures façons il est là une des
meilleures aussi parce que on utilise
tous les jours c'est notre téléphone
c'est la fin de ce journal les
programmes se poursuivent sur tv fil 78
replay a consulté a consultés sur notre
site internet et puis également sur
notre application un mobile vous en avez
maintenant l'habitude les programmes se
poursuivre
[Musique]